single father homes have better outcomes
than single mother homes but the best
outcomes is the parents together and
because our whole society is pandering
to women voting and getting money from
women because women make 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions so we live in
a society that's just constantly telling
us what we want to hear all of the time
we've basically been brainwashed for the
last hundred years to think that women
can really be equal to men but the truth
of the matter is is that men run Society
they run all of the industries that make
Society run the only reason that women
out earn men is because we can monetize
Beauty and men have subsidized
Industries so men pay their taxes and
the government takes their taxes to make
companies have quotas for women or
they're not as productive as men